I'm quite satisfied as far as the
statement is concerned the meeting took
place in better than expected
atmosphere I was reading before coming
here that this would be attention which
session it was not it was based on
consensus and everyone was making the
efforts allowing us to come to common
conclusions from the Commission's point
of view it seems to me to be very
important that the council agreed to ask
institutions and the governments to work
speedily on the priority actions
proposed by by the Commission that's
what we are doing and I can briefly
remind you what these proposals are and
we will work on the basis of these
conclusions on the details of the
Commission's action program I had the
opportunity already today to explain
that we do think that we have to get to
to go further than the discussion of the
last week's was reflecting our actions
we do think that we need 100 more for
emergency assistance for the most
affected member states we do think that
we need 600 million more for the few
agencies in 2016 200 million more for
the World Food Program in 2015
300 million more for you mean 7 8 in
2016 and more funds to stabilize our
immediate neighbourhood up to 1 billion
for Turkey and 7 our vision for the
Former Yugoslav Republic of Macedonia
this conclusion that the statement
issued is allowing us to work on that
basis and that's exactly what we are
doing in the next coming days it was an
accent